stand and deliver
that's all i got
[Music]
should i just start going straight to
credits
i i i don't i don't know is it just that
i don't have a lot to say
sometimes and that's the thing i'm
actually not uh gonna have a lot to say
on this episode i've i've started taking
notes on my viewings which i didn't used
to but like
normally i get a full page of notes
that's all i've got for this one
and it that's not even because it's bad
if it was bad i'd have a heck of a lot
more notes
but it's the concepts that it's
dealing with are well explored but it
is just kind of taking those concepts
and just sticking with them
start to finish it isn't shifting it
isn't in
involving an a lot of additional things
part of that may be because
clara is absent which is actually
something i kind of appreciate no that's
not a dig at clara but like
i feel that we i feel like
fans talk about oh should we have
another dr light episode like how about
uh
how about a few more companion light
episodes you know
something like midnight something like
this where
the doctor is missing his usual support
system
now midnight took much better advantage
of that idea than
this does but you know i think giving
the companion a rest now and then and
having the doctor deal with something
on his own that's valid
i'm here for that um but it may be the
fact that we are now
as a result we are lacking the
overarching elements of the development
and the exploration of
clara and the doctor's relationship
which has been a surprisingly big part
of this series like more than i remember
it being and that's
to its credit so far um even
even though i don't always like what
it's doing like the fact that that's an
ongoing thing
that's a good thing and
lacking that extra element means that
basically all this thing's got going for
it
is the plot and some of the themes it
doesn't have that extra layer of
what's also going on with clara and the
doctor which makes it feel
just very basic has taken on a
cruel implication like oh that's just
basic i don't mean it like that but like
it just feels
kind of run-of-the-mill kind of standard
kind of you know maybe even
lacking a little bit but not because of
any issues of quality just because
there's
fewer elements at play so
what i will say is i said last time that
they did not use maisie williams very
well
in the girl who died basically that
could have been played by
any young actress here they take much
better advantage of her
and her acting range and her ability to
go
cold which is something that game of
thrones also uh used her quite well for
and that you know you can really doubt
her intention her um moral
compass and she can make you wonder is
it still there she can play the pain
very well i actually think that the
doctor going through
her journals and going through you know
some of the
the things that she suffers through
particularly we have that scene where
she is she is crying over
cribs of dead children her children
and that is powerful and that
hurts me to watch and especially knowing
that you know later on she says you know
the really bad memories i rip out of
these journals
and the dark says what could be worse
than losing your kids she said i leave
that in to remind myself never to do it
again
like that dang
man that's rough and i i do find a lot
of the core
concepts of what's going on with i don't
know whether i should color her shoulder
or me i'll probably keep calling her
shoulder for now the doctor does
partly to antagonize her but whatever
so i there's a lot that i enjoy about
this
i like that it addresses the idea
because this was something that like
douglas adams also touched on
with um dirk gently's holistic detective
agency
that the brain is not infinite it's got
limited storage capacity and so
she is living so much longer than humans
were
ever built to last and while
the chip that was put into her is
healing her body
it can't expand her mind to be able to
encompass
all these experiences that is far more
than
she was ever supposed to be able to have
and so she keeps forgetting stuff
anything that she doesn't deem as extra
important or she doesn't
uh you know that doesn't have a reason
to really get lodged in there
or that she doesn't write down you know
that's just going to fade away
with time because you can't save
everything here
and and like i said douglas adams did a
similar thing with
with a time traveling character in in
dirk gently's holistic detective agency
so there is uh that's always that
concept that i that i've
liked like one of the unforeseen
consequences of
living too long that that's an
interesting one that again not truly
original but i
i do like that concept so i'm happy to
see it here
the moral ambiguity of her i think is
also pretty well played
because there's a little bit of
for lack of a better comparison the
groundhog's day
scenario so in groundhog's day
and most sort of time loops or granted
she's not on a loop she just keeps going
but you know bill murray's character
goes through a number of phases
confusion
and then sort of rapturous joy like i
can do anything
and then later this melancholy of
what's the point i'm still gonna be here
unchanged no matter what i do and i feel
like
she's hit that period or um
maybe she may be in the beginning or the
tail end of it but
she's definitely had it and it does make
you think
like i we can't count on her having the
same moral center
that she did the last time we saw her
because
she's been around too long she's
she's seen and done and lost too much
that now she's just kind of checked out
a bit and the i even though i'm going to
call her a shoulder
because it's just awkward to say me i
suppose i could say lady me
but i don't know it doesn't roll off the
tongue well
i do actually really like the
explanation as to why she calls herself
that
i think that's that's a very cool idea
and again
plays into all the things she's
forgotten again i think that
that's that's good stuff some of the
other elements
sam swift the quick or something like
that
he he's fun i i actually i actually kind
of
enjoy him you know this guy who
who is operating on this desperate
assumption if i can keep these people
happy
maybe they won't kill me
[Laughter]
and and i i i like how how that
plays out and how that works especially
at the end and especially
given the doctor's normal
thing against banter and actually
specifically saying you know i don't
like puns which is basically saying i
don't like dad jokes but then he
willingly participates at the very end
when sam swift might get hanged in order
to keep this guy alive for a little
while i like that the doctor
willingly participates in something he
just announced because
maybe it'll save a guy because yeah
that's the doctor i don't have that much
more to talk about
um i suppose i can get to the cat thing
hold off on that
but the the interactions between the
doctor and the shielder
um i her grievances with him feel pretty
earned
he left her behind he left her
and in a situation that a human being is
not supposed to be in
with no guidance no help
and he didn't come back he didn't even
come back for a now he ran into her out
of sheer coincidence he can
see the frustration in her face when she
realizes that
he didn't even come back to see her now
on purpose it was by
accident and that that feels like she's
got a
pretty legitimate bone to pick with him
on that
um i really love the
importance of the mayflies speech
that the doctor has you know this thing
that he says to us like it's important
for those of us who live as long as we
do
to be around people who don't
they know how beautiful and precious
life is because it's fleeting
and we need to be around them so
something reminds us because
on our own we can forget that and she
kind of had
and and i like that and there's all
there's also a line that the doctor has
that
i really like uh it's something like you
know you can
you can try not caring but eventually
you're going to fall off the wagon like
that that feels like a quick sum up of
basically series eight the doctor kind
of tried
being colder and not caring but it it
didn't take
did it and thank goodness um but i i
like that as a summation so
the cat thing i think that this is the
main weakness with this episode so like
most of the rest of the material is good
not great
but good and solid but this whole thing
with this cat alien deceiving her
it doesn't feel organically integrated
at all like i i buy that in the absence
of the doctor
if she thinks she has experienced
everything she is ever that is worth
experiencing here on earth that she is
willing to go to
some notable lengths to get into the
stars but they don't integrate
this particular character into the story
in order to facilitate that
they kind of use the fact that well
she's justified in wanting to get off
planet as just a reason to do and i
guess uh
cat alien yeah sure why not
no the question isn't why not the
question is why you don't really have an
answer
do you it's not awful but
it just it doesn't feel like it's from
the same story
again her desire that fits
the themes and the ideas being explored
but this being and how he looks and how
he acts
and the fact that he deceives her none
of this factors in
to the themes it's just kind of there i
feel like for sake of an action
e wrap up which i don't think the thing
needed i almost kind of wish that they
accept
excised that completely and this was
just
down to philosophical debate between
a shoulder and the doctor and the doctor
having to convince her
of the value of life again without an
additional alien element
i don't think like i understand some of
the narrative function that
the alien aspects have in this but i
feel like
the other elements would have been
richer
if they didn't have to share space with
this thing because it's not contributing
to what the rest of the episode's doing
which is kind of a bummer because a bit
like the episode before
it has really good moments that make a
episode
ah pretty good but it it could have been
more
and in this unlike um the girl who died
where like i didn't necessarily have a
suggestion for how to really elevate it
here i do
get rid of the cat just ditch the cat
find some other thing that she can do
that will cause some degree of chaos
that will wake her up and remind her
i'm not okay with collateral damage like
this
just find a way there are ways to do it
without having to introduce an
alien and again i come back to the
saying i feel like doctor who modern
doctor who especially
has this idea that well we have to have
an alien every second no you don't
you've got a sci-fi element already so
it's not like it would be a pure
historical
but you don't need an alien every time
and sometimes it just feels like it's
there out of obligation and that's
what's
kind of the thing here so that's the
woman who lived
it's decent better use of maisie
williams as i said some pretty good
themes some good interactions but
doesn't quite come together because
there's this rock in the middle of the
soup this
cat-shaped rock
what am i on about i don't know and you
probably don't either
but that'll wrap it up for this one
folks so
i have a patreon if you are willing and
able to help me out there
that would be incredibly helpful but
failing that liking sharing subscribing
and of course if you have re-watched
this episode lately or you have any
thoughts i would love to hear them down
in the comments and let's talk about it
so that'll wrap it up for this one folks
you don't have to do any of the things i
just suggested
i would appreciate it but end of the day
you're the council
i just run the meeting so until next
time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bye